[Musique]
je n'avais pas connaissance de cette
situation d' atos avant que ce soit le
maire par contre j'en ai eu connaissance
effectivement dès que j'ai pris mes
fonctions et c'est pour cela que dès le
mois de septembre
j'ai rencontré l'entreprise atos à ce
sujet je ne reproche absolument rien
atos il y à une transparence de la part
d' atos vis-à-vis de nous il ya
malheureusement des cas dramatiques qui
sont vécues dans cette entreprise je
pense que les mesures et les aces qui
s'appelle le gast qui est à l'heure
actuelle mise en place au travers de
cette société donneront les donnerons
les conclusions mais moi je n'ai
absolument pas juger atos
ça ne peut pas se traiter comme ça entre
ma faute ou pas ou pas ma faute je pense
qu' ils sont en train de prendre toutes
les mesures pour connaître l'origine de
ces cancers si l'origine est une origine
du de cette société ou pas moi je ne
peux absolument pas me prononcer sur ce
sur ce sujet ma position elle est claire
vis-à-vis gâteau c'est à dire une autre
une transparence sur ce qui s'est passé
sur le site ce qu'ils ont et aussi nous
avons saisi la rs madame le maire
précédent l'avait saisi également mais
je les ai de nouveau eu en télévisuelle
cette semaine pour avoir des mesures sur
l'environnement au niveau de la de la
commune des clayes-sous-bois de manière
à la également avoir des informations
factuelles pour la population